Speaker 1: We have yet another potential Trump
criminal scandal on our hands. Donald Trump's
Saudi Arabia payments are sparking fresh calls for
sparking calls for a fresh investigation. Writes
U.N. Palmor for Newsweek. That's take a look at
this article. Donald Trump should be investigated
over the payments he received to host the Saudi
Arabia backed live golf tour at his resorts.
According to an organization set up by supporters
of the murdered journalist Jamal Khashoggi. The
democracy for the Arab World Now Group has called
for the DOJ and Congress to look into the, quote,
disturbing facts and circumstances surrounding
that golf tour and ties to Trump. On January 13th,
it was revealed during court proceedings that the
Saudi Arabia Public Investment Fund, that's the
sovereign wealth fund headed by the country's
crown prince, Mohammed bin Salman, owns 93%
of live and pays 100% of the costs. Dionne claims
this is the first time that the full extent of the
sovereign wealth funds ownership in live golf has
been disclosed. Understand that this immediately
points to money transfers from the Saudi royal
family through that sovereign wealth fund to
Trump by virtue of paying to host the live golf
tournaments at Trump's golf courses, including
Bedminster in 2022. This potentially relates
to money laundering. This potentially relates
to an influence scam. And of course, all of the
answers to what we are looking for are found in
Hunter Biden's laptop. Right. That must be
the answer. No, listen, in all seriousness,
we all suspected this. We all suspected that
this golf tournament and Saudi Arabia and this
goes beyond just the United States. This was
a mechanism to transfer huge amounts of money.
It could be to Trump, it could be to other
other world leaders, because there are live golf
tournaments in various places. And when we talk
about Trump and influence peddling, it already is
it's beyond the pale that Trump's Washington, D.C.
hotel is not the subject of more scrutiny, because
during Trump's presidency, that hotel was a nexus
of massive money transfers and demolish events
that were received by Trump world leaders looking
to ingratiate themselves with Donald Trump,
saying, Hey, well, I'll stay at Trump's hotel and
I'll mention that I'm staying at Trump's hotel,
that it's a it's a borderline crime that that
hasn't been further investigated. But this one
was so obvious. This is so obvious. Trump was
criticized for hosting a bunch of different
live golf events at his resorts, but we didn't
understand the full scope of what is essentially
the royal family owning this entire thing. The
Saudi royal family controls the sovereign wealth
fund. Sovereign Wealth Fund owns 93% of the golf
tournament and pays 100% of those costs. This is
the revelation in practice that millions of
dollars from the Saudis have been going not
in terms of arms deals. Arms deals are bad enough,
but at least they are public or semipublic. This
was a subterfuge of sorts. There should be another
investigation and it is exhausting to even keep
up with this. The other aspect to the Saudi
Trump connection is, of course, Jared Kushner
and Jared Kushner's role and connections and
relationships with these very same folks involved
in the sovereign wealth fund. Are we ever going
to know the full scope? I don't believe we are.
I don't know that we are ever going to unwind
everything that went on during those insane
four years, But one of the things we can do
is do everything within our power to prevent
there being another four years just like it.
Make sure you are subscribed on YouTube to the
David Pakman. Show it youtube.com slash The David
Pakman Show. We really need your help. Something
is happening on YouTube with the algorithm where
it's not just The David Pakman Show. Many channels
like ours are being deprioritized. It has been
years since we have talked about this because
it has not been an issue for years. Something is
happening systematically to a half dozen channels
like ours and it seems to be algorithmic. So
the best thing you can do. Leave a comment
like our videos and make sure that you
are indeed subscribed. We're going to
take a quick break and the Friday
show rolls on right after this.